les nouvelles cimes 4s 107 et 13 108
viennent de faire leur apparition
automoto les essaiera pour vous au début
du mois de septembre
nous avons voulu vous les montrer avant
l'essai complet que nous leur consacrons
m
il s'agit de limousines cinq places 5
portes traction avant d'en moteur de 13
centimètres cubes de base dont les
normes de sécurité ont été
particulièrement étudiés
nous y reviendrons
non bien sûr ce n'est pas de l'ancien
quatre chevaux nous allons vous
entretenir mais de ce que beaucoup
considèrent un peu comme sa petite soeur
la toute nouvelle renault 5 depuis le
début du mois de janvier ça 150
journalistes spécialisés de la presse
française et européenne ont défilé à
quiberon pour en faire un premier essai
sur les routes du morbihan faut préciser
d'ailleurs qu'il y avait très longtemps
que la présentation officielle d'un
nouveau modèle ne s'était fait dans
notre région la renault 5 d'une voiture
compacte
longue de 3 mètres 50 proposés en deux
portes et un hayon arrière
suivant sa puissance quatre ou cinq
chevaux et sa finition intérieure elle
est disponible en deux versions elle
était elle comme en témoigne son
encombrement et sa maniabilité
cette voiture a été initialement conçue
pour la ville on constate qu'il y a un
besoin de voiture au coeur des villes
qu'ils une extension de la périphérie
des villes et qu'il y à aussi de plus en
plus des liaisons de ville à ville et
c'est un problème qui est lié à
l'urbanisme de notre temps qui nous
avons cherché à faire un véhicule qui
s'y adaptent au mieux
c'est une voiture qui consomme moins de
6 litres aux cent et qui vous le disiez
vous avez raison en est une
se conduit comme à domicile quatre
manières sur la route la renault 5 à
vous des similitudes avec la 4l dont
elle reprend du reste en partie la
mécanique
à ce sujet on peut préciser qu'un
certain nombre de pièces du châssis en
particulier sont fabriqués dans des
usines de la région à hennebont et aux
membres notamment
compte tenu des normes actuelles de
limitation la vitesse de pointe est
satisfaisante
plus de 120 kilomètres heure pour la
version 4 chevaux et 135 km heure pour
le modèle plus puissant
le confort a été également soigné avec
une attention particulière la suspension
et souple l'habitabilité intérieur
spacieuse au point d'accueillir quatre
personnes
la finition joue sur le principe des
options pour vous livrer une voiture
pourvu de vitres teintées possédant un
toit ouvrant et équipé d'un récepteur
radio el hout est elle normale ou
raffiner la renault 5 de toute façon
sera livrable à partir du mois de
février
un avis détails mais il a je crois une
importance primordiale
les prix les plis sur le modèle renault
5 l
il est à 9740 francs et le modèle tl est
à dix mille neuf cent soixante francs
toutes taxes comprises bien entendu
auparavant une certaine élite disait
ferrari jaguar rolls royce mercedes ou
geek
aujourd'hui ils disent citroën sm à
moteur maserati pour juger l'une des
dernières nées de la technique française
nous l'avons piloter sur l'autoroute est
incontestablement cette voiture de tout
premier plan à carrosserie aérodynamique
mû par un 6 cylindres en v à boîte à six
vitesses réunit une synthèse parfaite de
qualité aux causes et sécurité et
confort exceptionnel allier haute
performance des voitures de sport
ce qui surprend le plus c'est le système
de direction à rappelle a servi la
direction directe à 200 km à leur
produit une impression de très grande
souplesse et aux allures rapide que nous
avons emprunté elle devient plus ferme
maintenant le véhicule à très haute
vitesse sur la trajectoire désirer cela
avec une précision parfaite
le passage des vitesses de cette voiture
donné à 180 chevaux et c'est à 6250
tours/minute de s'effectue sans
difficulté la menthe tombant
naturellement sur le levier de vitesse
seize chevaux fiscaux 6 cylindres en v
une consommation variant entre 13 et 21
litres sont les premiers chiffres
intéressants celui qui admire l'asn
nous sommes très rapidement habitué à la
conduite à très haute vitesse est bien
calé dans un siège baquet le corps
souple et l'esprit attentifs les aspects
les plus séduisants de la voiture nous
apparaissent tout en étant pris par la
parfaite visibilité de l'habitacle
freinage exceptionnel confort inégalé
sur une voiture roulant à cette vitesse
les spécialistes sont unanimes à ce
sujet la citroën sm à moteur maserati
présente un ensemble de qualité jamais
réunis sur une voiture
automobilisme encore mais pour une
première cette fois avec le nouveau
modèle citroën la gs que la firme
française commercialise ce mois ci et
qui se situe entre l'ami 8 et la ds ce
modèle est appelé à devenir le véhicule
de grande diffusion chez citroën
la présentation de cette dernière nous a
été rendue possible grâce à l'obligeance
de la nouvelle concession citroën qui
vient de s'ouvrir à arles et c'est en
camargue bien sûr que nous avons fait sa
connaissance
le moteur est un 4 cylindres à plat
opposés 2 à 2 à arbre à cames en tête
doté d'un refroidissement à air la gs
est une traction avant technique
affectionné par site wenn depuis fort
longtemps déjà
boîte à quatre vitesses synchronisée
elle possède quatre freins à disque est
assisté par le système hydraulique
avant
ces performances sont plus que valable
la vitesse maxi est donné à 149 km heure
pour une consommation moyenne de 7 à 8
litres à 80 km/heure de moyenne
le tableau de bord est sobre tout en
étant complet
en apprenant la bonne
la direction de la gs est extrêmement
précise et la liaison au sol a été conçu
pour obtenir une parfaite et grande
rigidité
ligne fonctionne l original ligne
aérodynamique dans le style citroën
la gs offre une visibilité parfaite et
une habitabilité excellente
la citroën gs c'est également une
voiture qui ne recule devant rien même
devant des taureaux de camargue qui en
été les premiers surpris
pandalabs
la balade
bon d'accord
bah
avec la citroën c6 elle il faut dès
maintenant revoir toutes les conceptions
que nous avions en matière d'automobile
en effet imaginez un peu que vous n'ayez
que 85 francs en poche pour aller de
paris à bordeaux et bordeaux à paris
soit 1079 km et bien c'est 85 3 ans
représentent 68 litres de gasoil 68
litres sur la capacité du réservoir de
la cx diesel si vous n'aimez pas la
route prenez donc l'autoroute et à 123
yens vous pourrez couvrir les 8 109
kilomètres qui séparent paris de
marseille à première vue c'est assez
surprenant
ça l'est beaucoup moins lorsqu'on sait
que la cx est mue par un moteur diesel
et que ce diesel est enrobé d'une
carrosserie particulièrement profil
ceci explique cela avec ses neuf chevaux
fiscaux la cx est la plus rapide et
diesel existants 152 km heure en vitesse
de pointe lutte est très longue à
obtenir qu'avait rapport intermédiaire
sont très courts 15 km heure en
premières quarante ans deuxième un peu
plus de 80 en troisième
au volant de la sig diesel il faut
adopter un nouveau style de conduite il
faut piloter comme avec une boîte
automatique est enclenché le plus
rapidement possible la troisième ou la
quatrième quart le moteur est très
souple et ne souffre pas même à bas
régime essais que nous avons effectués
sur les routes du bas libérons nous a
aussi permis de constater que le niveau
sonore à l'intérieur de la voiture est
très bas en revanche les 21 kilos
supplémentaires sur le train avant
apporte un peu de lourdeur dans les
réactions la direction pourtant assisté
sur l'a6 2002 essayer une chose encore
le diesel n'est pas nouveau chez citroën
il équipe déjà à 20000 utilitaire c'est
une bonne carte de visite et sur cette
carte de visite on pourra également lire
tenue de route excellente freinage sur
suspension citroën et prix d'achat 40
1800 francs